الانسحاب من خرسان هزيمه لا يبدو ان مؤيدي
الحرب الروس
يستسيغونها بل على العكس تاثيراتها باتت
تاخذهم الى مطالبات اقل ما توصف بالغريبه
او غير الواقعيه اولى هذه المطالبات اتت
من اعلاميا روسيا شهير يسوق للدعايه
الروسيه يدعى فلاديمير سلوفيا وهو حليف
للرئيس بلاد بوتين طلب الكلام بشني حرب
شامله في اوروبا لدفع حلف شمال الاطلسي
للتراجع بعد انسحاب روسيا من غير سون
الاوكرانيه كانت خرسون اكبر مركز حضاري
احتلته القوات الروسيه منذ ان شلنا الكرام
لان حربه على اوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين
من فبراير الماضي كانت ايضا العاصمه
الاقليميه الوحيده التي استولت عليها
موسكو عندما اجتمع بوت مع رؤساء المناطق
الاربعه في الثلاثين من سبتمبر الماضي
اعلن حينها ان تلك المناطق اصبحت روسيه
الى الابد
ولم يكن لم يدوم ذلك لشهرين ربما يفسر هذا
او يفسر هذا سر الغضب فلاديمير
[موسيقى]
قديم
نيترو
المروج
الى خطوط عام
1998 اي قبل ان تنضم دول اوروبا الشرقيه
للحلف مثل لاتفيا واسبانيا وليتوانيا
انه يجب التغلب عليها بقبضه من حديد واضاف
ان ذلك يشمل اطلاقا النار على الجبناء
واعاده الحثاله البكائين الى رشدهم على حد
تعبيرها الاهالي بالاعلام وهتافات ترحيب
ارسلت مواطنه الاوكرانيه صورا لمنازل في
المدينه كانت تحتلها القوات الروسيه اظهرت
الصور غرفا تعرضت مليئه بالقمامه والاشياء
المدمره على الارض وقالت لمجله نيوز ويك
الامريكيه الروس لا يعرفون معنى الحريه
وهم يشبعون بدعايه خاطئه
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه نشرت مقطع فيديو
عبر حسابها في تويتر يجمع مقاطع لسكان
خرسون وهم يلوحون بالاعلام الاوكرانيه
وقالت ان اهالي خرسان لم يستسلم قط
[موسيقى]
خلال ثمانيه اشهر من الحرب لم يحقق الجيش
الروسي سوى تقدمات ضائله واجبر مرارا على
التراجع نرى هنا مشاهدينا على هذه الخريطه
تظهر الفارق في مساحه السيطره الروسيه في
اوكرانيا بين مارس 20 22 واليوم والتي تعد
اقل بحوالي 50% الان يسمع في روسيا اصوات
اكثر تشددا وان كانت غير واقعيه اذ خرجت
تظاهرات في شوارع موسكو تطالب بشني ضربه
نوويه على واشنطن العاصمه الامريكيه انتشر
مقطع فيديو يظهر رجلا يقود حشدا من الناس
في شوارع موسكو ويصرخ اضربوا مراكز اتخاذ
القرار في واشنطن بصاروخ صار مات اضرب مدن
العدو في واشنطن
ردد المتظاهرون ايضا شعارا يقول سنذهب الى
الجنه كشهداء في اشاره الى التعليقات التي
ادلى بها الرئيس الروسي نفسه عام 2018 في
ذلك الوقت
لا مفر منه وانه سيتم ابادته سنذهب الى
الجنه شهداء
وسيسقطون امواتا ولن يكون لديهم وقت
للتوبه